how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and if things weren't
already
insanely exciting with the one division
series coming out the falcon and the
winter soldier series coming out and of
course all of this new news about
spider-man 3 and the multiverse that
could possibly happen
things are getting even more exciting
for the mcu
as today we have a report and even a
document that suggests that
hugh jackman's wolverine could very
briefly
be returning to the marvel cinematic
universe and appear
along with some other of his fellow
original x-men
as well and our favorite x-force
character
deadpool now most of you have kept up to
date with everything that is happening
with spider-man 3.
spider-man is confirmed to be able to
jump into different universes
jamie foxx's electro is returning and
will be entering the mcu
and doctor strange is going to be in
spider-man 3 as well and of course he
has the ability to go between universes
also
we have rumors and reports that toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man are going to be returning for
spider-man 3 along with some other
sony spider-man characters so spider-man
3 is going to be a huge
movie but it looks like marvel isn't
going to stop there
it looks like marvel studios is going to
go all out
with doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness
as it looks like hugh jackman's
wolverine is returning for a quick
little cameo deadpool is going to enter
the mcu and some
other original x-men characters could be
joining as well
and we even have a document to back this
up as well
so it looks like we could be getting
what we've been wanting hugh jackman's
wolverine in the marvel cinematic
universe
alongside ryan reynolds's deadpool the
combination that everybody has been
wanting to see in the marvel cinematic
universe for a very long time
so to start off there have been tons of
rumors and reports that hugh jackman's
wolverine is going to be returning in
multiverse of madness but the biggest
thing
is a document that has been shared by
daniel rpk
it's a studio document that says date 09
10
20 20 activity offer out to and
talent hugh jackman and it's been
reported that this
is indeed for multiverse of madness so
marvel studios wants hugh jackman for
multiverse of madness but
what exactly do they want him for what
does this mean
well this actually probably means one of
two very different things one
is pretty simple he's going to come back
as wolverine and multiverse of madness
but he's not going to come back
in any other movie besides this movie
for a quick cameo
the problem that fans and marvel studios
would have with bringing hugh jackman's
wolverine back
into the marvel cinematic universe for
good would be it would offset
and undo everything that happened in the
fox universe and wolverine is arguably
the best thing to happen to the fox
universe and logan was an absolutely
incredible movie
and hugh jackman even said logan was his
farewell to the character
that was his goodbye so there was no way
hugh jackman was coming back to reprise
his character of logan
however multiverse of madness makes it
possible for him to enter the mcu for a
quick cameo it allows him to do two
things he can come back as wolverine the
same
wolverine from the fox universe and he
can come back without any consequences
to the other films
because again it's the multiverse he can
pop into our universe for a little bit
and then go back to his
own yes he died in logan but he is
wolverine so you never really know or
they could just simply get him from a
different point in time but the main
point is that it wouldn't take away from
his goodbye to logan it wouldn't change
any of his story
and the second thing multiverse of
madness does if he comes back as
wolverine is he would not have to commit
to 10 to 15 years of staying in peak
physical condition
and committing to a filming schedule
years and years in advance hugh jackman
has already stated that's not something
that he wants to do right now
plus he's a little bit older and it's
really hard to stay in really peak
physical condition however hugh jackman
did express
interest in appearing in the mcu and he
said if it was a few years earlier he
would probably do it so multiverse of
madness is the perfect opportunity for
hugh jackman just to take a step into
the mcu very briefly give the fans give
marvel studios and himself what
everybody wants
and then say goodbye again and that's
just one scenario of why marvel wants
him back for multiverse of madness but
there could be a second factor here
there haven't been any official reports
but there have been some rumors that
marvel could want him back to play
a different character now i know a lot
of people may not like this idea but it
is going to be a multiverse film it
could be done
really well and it could justify him
being a different character he's logan
and wolverine in one universe the fox
universe but in a different alternate
universe he could be a different
character either a hero
or a villain this option would still
allow him to be in the marvel cinematic
universe which again is something that
he has expressed and wanted to do
but as i mentioned in the first option
this would allow him to enter the mcu
make a quick cameo
have a lot of fun and not have to commit
to a character and it wouldn't undo his
goodbye to logan now it would be weird
to see hugh jackman playing a different
marvel character but hey it's happened
before with other actors
now another huge rumor that has been
going around is the fact that ryan
reynolds right now
is listed as a cast member for
multiverse of
madness now of course this could only
mean one thing
deadpool ryan reynolds is not going to
be playing another character
now right now he's listed on google and
imdb to be in multiverse of madness
which is in no way an
official confirmation however multiverse
of madness would be the absolute perfect
movie to introduce
deadpool into the marvel cinematic
universe and it's pretty similar reasons
to why hugh jackman's wolverine would be
perfect for multiverse of madness as
well you could bring
deadpool from the fox universe into the
mcu without changing
anything and this would be addressed of
course as well because
deadpool breaks the fourth wall it's
what he does and it's what we love him
for
fourth wall break inside a fourth wall
break that's like
16 walls so this actually lines up with
a report that says ryan reynolds is
about to sign
the biggest marvel studios deal in
history claiming to be bigger than the
deal that marvel studios had with robert
downey jr that means that ryan reynolds
would have to sign a deal for
and commit to nine movies but some of
these wouldn't exactly be starring roles
some of them would just be cameos or
supporting roles much like how falcon is
very briefly in ant-man or how iron man
is in spider-man homecoming so if
deadpool is in multiverse of madness
this would be the start of his nine
movie deal
and his start in the mcu now again it's
kind of the perfect opportunity strange
could accidentally bring deadpool from
the fox universe into the main universe
and then deadpool could just stay
imagine doctor strange accidentally
bringing deadpool
into the main universe deadpool shows up
but then he runs away making a joke
about going to explore the new universe
or going to try and meet thor
or a better looking hugh jackman
wolverine no matter how he arrives you
definitely know that it's going to be
funny doctor strange could tell him that
he needs to send him back but deadpool
manages to escape
and doctor strange is something like
well dang that's not good and from there
on out we have deadpool in the main
marvel cinematic universe
now of course with hugh jackman's
wolverine and ryan reynolds says
deadpool
both rumored to be in multiverse of
madness we could possibly see the two of
them together
in the mcu something that a lot of us
have wanted for a while
and it looks like we may just get our
wish even if it's briefly in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
now there have been some other reports
and rumors that some of the original
x-men could show up in doctor strange 2
as well
and it just makes perfect sense again
it's a way to bring these characters in
the mcu very briefly and not affect
anything that happened in the other
universe but we know for a fact that
doctor strange is going to be exploring
the multiverse so it just makes perfect
sense that he's going to run into other
characters while he explores these
universes
and this could be a tiny bit of fan
service but i also think that it's
something that everybody would enjoy and
it's something that would actually make
a lot of sense you're going to explore
other universes then you're definitely
going to meet
other alternate versions of characters
and this will kind of be a way to
introduce x-men into our mcu if they
exist in other universes then they most
likely exist in our main universe
either way it looks like doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness is going to
be an
insanely awesome movie and let's hope
that these reports and rumors are true
about hugh jackman's wolverine and ryan
reynolds deadpool showing up in
multiverse of madness
if you love marvel and love staying up
to date on everything be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
and i have recently partnered with
heroes hideout.com to give away some
awesome collectibles i'll be giving some
collectibles away from now until the end
of the holidays and if you're looking
for some great gifts either for yourself
or for your loved ones be sure to check
out heroeshideout.com
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you